non
politique après les municipales
renouvellement et rajeunissement
reconquête socialiste et trois grands
chelems dans de fpr à paris et à lyon
michel noir
invité de ce journal la force se crispe
bagarre à bastia le premier ministre
promet une série de tables rondes sur
les problèmes de l'île si le calme y
revient
réquisitoire tempéré à nanterre le
procureur blanchi le commissaire joe
beef les parties civiles frotte s
élections présidentielles dans la peur
et dans le sang au salvador le candidat
d'extrême droite se déclarent élus
révolutionnaire et luxueuse la plus
grosse citroën ax m
dévoile ses formes mais monsieur bon
soit il faut que le calme soit rétabli
en corse
c'est à cette condition que le premier
ministre vient de promettre une série de
tables rondes sur les problèmes de l'île
notamment les prix et la fonction
publique dans la tente de ce communiqué
de matignon la situation s'est tendue
aujourd'hui la grève générale du secteur
public entre dans sa cinquième semaine
il est toujours isolée et les
manifestations qui ont eu lieu à ajaccio
et à bastia surtout en mal tourné sur
place françoise unis premier tir de
grenade lacrymogène ils 14h30 les crs
riposte aux manifestants
cramponnés aux grilles de la préfecture
de bastia et qui menacent d'investir les
bâtiments
au gaz lacrymogènes quelques grévistes
eux répondent avec des pierres et autres
projectiles
deux pelotons de gendarmes mobiles
viennent renforcer la compagnie de crs
sur place de chaque côté on évite tout
affrontement direct mais deux crs seront
sérieusement blessé un manifestant plus
légèrement à 18h30 les 400 manifestants
se retire les syndicats ayant appelé à
la dislocation du rassemblement bastia
by maintenant une situation de plus en
plus difficile depuis cinq jours les
ordures ménagères s'entassent dans les
rues
toute la journée la ville a été
complètement isolée du continent et du
reste de l'île et transporteurs routiers
coupent les routes pour protester contre
le blocage du port par les grévistes
les commerçants s'inquiètent de leur
approvisionnement de ce quai de gare de
crèmerie fromage déçu peu de temps va
remonter parce que mon a le bac dont les
parents ont fait depuis vendredi six
mardi il n'arrive pas on sera pas mal de
choses ce soir à bastia
alors que la grève dans la fonction
publique dure maintenant depuis cinq
semaines
jamais la tension n'a été aussi vives
oui à paris le premier ministre avait
reçu ce matin une délégation de
parlementaires corses
le ministre de l'intérieur assister à
cette réunion
mais c'est en fin de journée seulement
que l'hôtel matignon vient d'arrêter sa
position rachid arhab louis christine
pour tenter de dénouer la crise corse
michel rocard propose donc un certain
nombre de tables rondes une table ronde
par exemple sur la question des prix et
de la concurrence qui est un peu à
l'origine de l'agitation sociale en
corse une agitation qui a donc amené le
premier ministre à recevoir ce matin
tous les parlementaires de l'île des
parlementaires à qui michel rocard a dit
que sur le problème des prix il est
effectivement anormal que le
consommateur corse payent plus cher que
sur le continent des biens courants qui
arrive dans l'île à un prix inférieur et
cela grâce aux allègements de tva michel
rocard a proposé deux autres tables
rondes sur la question du coût des
transports vers la corse et sur la
réforme de la fiscalité mais cela ne se
fera qu'à la mi-avril
d'ici là le premier ministre aura reçu
le rapport de monsieur tout le monde
l'inspecteur général des finances
qui est actuellement en mission en corse
pour le gouvernement michel rocard met
un préalable à la tenue de toutes ces
tables rondes ce préalable c'est le
retour au calme sur le territoire corse
le gouvernement ne veut donc pas cédé à
la pression du terrain pas céder à la
pression des syndicats sur la question
des salaires corse notamment une
question des salaires qui n'est pas
clairement évoquée dans le communiqué de
matignon qui comme vous le disiez
christine a quelque peu tardé alors
justement voyons tout de suite
maintenant là une première réaction
celle du représentant de la cgt
fonctionnaires de haute corse
je crois que c'est une grande déception
monsieur rocard et son gouvernement
méprisent le travail est en lutte
il n'est pas répondu aux revendications
qui sont posées par des milliers de
fonctionnaires de l'île monsieur rocard
ne pas ne parle pas des problèmes des
travailleurs de cette région
monsieur rocard préfère dialoguer avec
d'autres formations avec d'autres
catégories sociales
il y a une stratégie pour la corse que
le gouvernement applique qu est
contraire aux intérêts des salariés
aujourd'hui nous en sommes conscients
la cgt quant à elle demande aux salariés
demain matin à l'assemblée générale de
continuer la lutte parce que nous
pouvons gagner nous ferons reculer le
gouvernement aujourd'hui qu'il faut
négocier sur des mesures compensatoires
immédiate du rose au vert avec le
printemps le paysage politique dessine
une nouvelle palette de couleurs au
lendemain des municipales le parti
socialiste tantôt recentrer tantôt allié
aux communistes conquiert plus de
grandes villes qui n'en perd à la
différence de l'udf du rpr et du parti
communiste les verts et le front
national qui s'était souvent maintenu au
second tour confirment leur présence à
l'échelle nationale et vont donc
pénétrer de façon significative dans de
nombreux conseils municipaux deux
lectures au moins de ces résultats
s'enchevêtrent une lecture politique qui
en fait une victoire pour michel rocard
et son gouvernement est une leçon pour
l'opposition on le verra tout à l'heure
et puis une autre lecture frappante qui
souligne la volonté de renouvellement et
de rajeunissement des électeurs
deux tours donc de ces municipales âge
38 ans parti socialiste tendance rocard
formation théologie protestante et en
plus c'est une femme
bravo catherine trautmann vous avez
conquis strasbourg
vous êtes la première femme à diriger
une capitale régionale
votre portrait brossé par olivier lerner
quand catherine trautmann découvre le
star system secrétaire de section en 78
conseillère municipale en 83 députés en
86 secrétaire d'état éphémère du
gouvernement rocard
aujourd'hui maire de strasbourg
catherine trautmann devra désormais
conjuguer au pluriel son appellation de
mai et dans ta classe a pas des petits
camarades qui sont le d'udf au front
national et qui te regardent un nombre
d'eux un signe rennes qui est un peu
jalouse mais je n'y prête pas attention
je pense qu'un jour assez d'être premier
ministre au président de la république
je crois que l'expérience nous a en fait
maintenant depuis 86 où ils étaient
quand même très souvent absente à paris
d'avoir connu de sardjito ministre nous
a appris à organiser notre temps
autrement mais nous arrivons toujours à
garder du temps tous les quatre pour
nous retrouver et faire des choses
ensemble
sa première décision sera de stopper net
le projet de val chère à son
prédécesseur fidèle à sa réputation
catherine trautmann n'entend pas renier
pour le seul plaisir de gouverner suis
préparé psychologiquement à cette
victoire même si je n'en étais pas
certain
tout à fait et je pense maintenant
surtout à la tâche qui m'attend et je
suis prête à consacrer tout
tout le temps qu'il faudra et tous les
efforts qu'il faudra aussi pour cette
gym car seul aime énormément strasbourg
bascule à gauche pour la première fois
depuis 70 ans
la boîte aux lettres de l'heureuse élue
en est encore retourner oui le parti
socialiste conquiert donc strasbourg
mais aussi mulhouse et célestin l'alsace
bascule à l'exception de colmar qui
restent de justesse un fief udf cds ce
qui est intéressant à colmar c'est le
score des écologistes la plus forte
poussée verte du territoire avec plus de
24% des voix claire chazal et yanji
qu'elles sont à colmar
cette usine d'incinération près de
colmar pour lui tous les déchets
s'accumulent à quelques mètres seulement
de ces petits jardins potagers
mais il ya aussi le contournement
autoroutier prévu à 7 km de la ville qui
risquent de bétonner toute la forêt de
quoi déjà motivé bon nombre de
colmariens amoureux de la nature et des
vieilles pierres de leur ville bien sûr
et les pousser à voter écologistes ils
étaient 14 % au premier tour ils sont
24% depuis le second tour un record
national absolue est ce que le vote
écologiste est pas aussi un peu
politique de ranger des autres listes
sans doute qu'il ya une part de rejet
mais enfin je préfère voir les choses de
façon positive et dire que ce sont des
gens aussi bien des jeunes que les
personnes âgées qui nous ont dit en
ayant voté pour nous elles ont d'abord
je pense voter pour les solutions
d'avenir qui ne sont pas prises
actuellement en cours mais si colmar a
pu apporter si massivement son soutien
aux verts c'est aussi parce que les jeux
étaient faits de toute façon entre les
deux candidats traditionnels les cds
edmond gerrer installée à la mairie
depuis 77 avaient en effet bien peu a
craint du socialiste serge rozier un
candidat un peu pas le regard de ses
voisins catherine trautmann où jean
marie bockel pas d'enjeu donc pour les
électeurs de gauche qui ont pu sans état
d'âme voter autrement
autre phénomène intéressant la stabilité
du front national
là où ses candidats se sont maintenues
au second tour le parti de jean-marie le
pen c'est ses meilleurs scores dans le
sud du pays et emportent une mairie une
seule celle de saint gilles du gard
patrice volée
l'école de saint gilles ce matin à
découvrir la mairie à son extrême droite
pour 321 une voix le front national a
conquis l'écharpé tricolore ici sécurité
et immigration sont depuis des années au
coeur du débat municipal avec près de
25% d'étrangers sur 12000 habitants
j'ai jamais dit que je voulais prendre
les solutions draconiennes
j'ai tout simplement dit que je voulais
trouver des solutions aux mêmes je suis
un descendant des général lafayette je
connais parfaitement les terres de la
déclaration de l'homme puisque c'est des
droits de l'homme puisque c'est lui qui
l'a inspiré mais je crois aussi que
cette déclaration des droits de l'homme
comporte une partie très importante qui
sont les devoirs du citoyen monsieur le
maire c'est le versant aristocratique du
front national reconnu comme modéré très
fier d'une certaine ouverture sur sa
liste si rpr un émerger et 50% de
socioprofessionnels à saint gilles il
fait de la politique depuis à peine six
mois mais habite nîmes à 20 km moi je
pense qu'ils ont choisi l'image du front
national parce que les solutions il y en
a très peu qui a été proposé par
monsieur deux chambres pendant cette
campagne pour pas dire pratiquement au
puy
donc je pense que c'est plutôt l'image
du front national qu'ils ont choisi et
surtout le changement qu'ils évoluent
après une campagne sans vagues saint
gilles à voter front national pour
oublier les divergences du précédent
conseil municipal udf rpr sans pour
autant savoir ce que le nouveau maire
veut faire de leur ville difficile
d'affirmer ce soir que saint gilles sera
pour six ans le laboratoire des idées du
front national
arnaud de chambrun semble tenir à
l'indépendance de sa liste mixte mais
ses adversaires politiques ici craignent
le poids des instances nationales du
front sur la vie locale à l'échelle
nationale catherine trautmann ne
symbolise est tout à leur place aux
jeunes dont beaucoup de municipalités
le combat entre les anciens et les
modernes entre les caciques et les
genoux à privilégier la relève pascal
guimier et jean-michel merkel génération
municipal la relève
il était une fois deux jeunes loups face
à de vieux renard ou bien linverse
amiens gilles de robien 47 ans député
udf le tombeur de rené landes 73 ans
maire sortant après 18 ans de gestion
communiste amiens bascule à droite ici
claude malhuret ancien secrétaire d'état
aux droits de l'homme figurent des
partis républicains victorieux d'un
autre p r jacques lacarin mer depuis
deux décennies
mais il a 76 ans alençon alain lambert
43 ans notaire de son état 8% qui font
la différence face à peer mais j'ai 62
ans socialiste installée à la mairie
pendant deux mandats mulhouse jean marie
bockel 38 ans avocat anser secrétaire
d'état devant ce des trois points le
maire udf de 57 ans joseph klifa
et puis il y à ces jeunes loups qui se
mange d'entre eux la quarantaine et
parfois gourmande valenciennes jean
louis borloo 37 ans avocat d'affaires
sans carte de parti il crée la surprise
76% des voix face au jeune communiste
jean claude dulieu 35 ans enfin bègles
noël mamère 40 ans journaliste arrache
aux communistes leur unique enclave dans
la communauté urbaine de bordeaux
bernard moncla 44 ans 46% des voix doit
céder sa place oui il ya quand même
quelques exceptions dans l'autre sens
trois grands chelems sur la ligne plm
les trois plus grandes villes de france
se sont chacune donné un seul homme
jacques chirac à paris michel noir à
lyon robert vigouroux à marseille le
détail avec laurent boursiers au rugby
au bridge ou en politique pour faire le
grand chelem il n'y a pas de secret il
faut être fort dans tous les domaines
pour jacques chirac ce grand chelem a
été long à se dessiner son ailier du 20e
didier bariani a bien failli passer en
touche
à 21h30 hier soir ils étaient donnés
battus avant de réaliser un
rétablissement spectaculaire qui lui a
permis de gagner avec 536 mois d'avant
comment 83 jacques chirac a transformé
tous ces essais 20 sur 20 pour un
deuxième grand chelem
la victoire peut aussi sourire aux
remplaçants entrés en milieu de partie
test matches réussis pour robert
vigouroux qui avec ses amis bouscule les
équipes politique de marseille
3 + 5 eca 8 lui secteur gagnait grand
chelem réussi grâce à un essai sur
l'ailé gauche aux dépens du communiste
guy hermier candidats sur les listes de
michel pezet et grâce à un essai sur
l'ailé droite qui prive jean claude
gaudin de sa chair mairie
d'arrondissement
enfin pour gagner il faut faire preuve
d'un bel élan avec son physique de
deuxième ligne michel noir devient le
premier maire gaulliste de lyon il met
fin à près d'un siècle de radicalisme et
de centrisme dans cette ville neuf
secteurs sur neuf ont voté pour lui ce
qui le met en position de force et dans
sa ville et dans son parti
oui c'est à lyon que la victoire
complète de michel noir a le moins
surpris il faut bien le dire vu son
score au premier tour et c'est pourtant
lui qui à tarnos plus près la
physionomie de ces municipales 89 michel
noir bonsoir et bravo alors dites-nous
est-ce que vous avez reçue hier soir à
un coup de téléphone de félicitations de
jacques chirac
oui tout à fait comme dimanche dernier
j'ai eu l'occasion de féliciter aussi
d'adresser mes félicitations à jacques
chirac puisque nous avons partagé cette
même performance du grand chelem
tout au long de votre campagne et même
entre les deux tours vous avez préféré
un adjectif à votre étiquette et refaire
cet adjectif c'est moral
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que qu'avant
vous ou à côté de vous les autres hommes
politiques ne sont pas entre guillemets
moreau bon ça veut dire que s'il ya une
sorte de décalage horaire entre une
grande partie de l'opinion publique
française et les politiques c'est parce
que les français ont le sentiment que la
politique ne tourne pas rond parce que
trop éloignés des choses de la vie des
choses de la vie la réussite scolaire
des enfants
la considération apportée aux personnes
à l'automne de la vie
la dimension du code du cadre de vie
et de l'habitat dans une grande cité
toutes ces choses qui concernent la vie
quotidienne ont beaucoup d'importance et
les politiques quand ils cèdent à leur
jeu favori des étiquettes des petites
phrases des jeux politiciens leur semble
trop éloigné c'est ça le message de
croix principal de ces élections
municipales et dans ses jeux favoris
mais aussi la stratégie est ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu surpris de constater
qu'au fond c'est en tout cas le
sentiment qu'on art de l'extérieur la
gauche applaudit plus volontiers encore
à votre succès que votre propre parti
des repères dans ce qui est vrai c'est
que environ 20 à 25 % d'électeurs qui
avaient choisi la gauche aux
présidentielles ou législatives ont eux
voté en faveur de ma candidature
ce qui traduit bien le fait que les
hommes politiques qui paraissent au delà
des étiquettes ouvert aux réalités
partageant ou même courageux sur les
valeurs de tolérance et de respect de
l'autre sont crédibles dès l'instant où
ils se préoccupent de traduire tout cela
dans une sorte de morale de l'action
c'est intéressant je le répète pardonnez
moi cette répétition aux choses
concrètes de la vie et ça c'est un
message que vous adressez surtout aux
instances dirigeantes du rpr ça je crois
que ça concerne l'ensemble des
formations politiques la classe
politique ces dernières années a pris
cinq ou six fuseaux horaires de décalage
horaire par rapport à la société par
rapport aux problèmes concrets auxquels
nos concitoyens souhaitent que le
pouvoir s'intéresse et on nous signifie
ça je dirais par avertissements
d'huissier pour l'instant sans frais
mais prenons garde au deuxième
avertissement et puis ça dépend pour qui
michel noir alain juppé a annoncé une
refonte du bureau politique des repères
et la nomination de nouveaux secrétaires
nationaux c'est une promotion qui vous
intéresseraient et à quelles conditions
pour vous non pour l'instant ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'on me laisse
travailler à lyon dans quatre jours
j'aurai l'honneur et l'immense tâche
d'être maire de lyon et de devoir à la
fois faire en sorte qu'on puisse mieux
vivre ensemble à lyon mais aussi qu'on
préparera à 15 ans le devenir de cette
cité qui a tout lieu de considérer
qu'elle peut jouer les premiers rôles en
coupe d'europe des villes championnes
des années 90 voilà du pain sur la
planche et je souhaite qu'on me laisse
travailler et vous irez aux européennes
le 18 juin prochain
alors moi je me suis appliqué depuis dix
ans le principe de non-cumul de mandats
donc
je ne vais pas commencer demain à
m'écarter de ce principe vous savez que
je suis très sourcilleux sur le respect
des principes donc lyonnais vous êtes
lyonnais vous restez michel noir merci
pour beaucoup d'hommes politiques sinon
ceux qui l'ont gagné mais en tout cas
pour les stratèges une élection chasse
l'autre c'est aussi le cas des
éditorialistes fini les municipales
pensant leclerc oui si la personnalité
des candidats et le caractère local de
la consultation municipal ont compté
avant tout dans la démarche des
électeurs les leçons politiques de ce
scrutin vont peser tout de même sur le
prochain rendez vous électoral
nul n'ignore le jeu bipolaire contesté
par ces deux derniers dimanches par les
verts et le front national risquent
d'être encore bousculer le 18 juin
prochain
l'élection européenne n'a pas de
conséquence politique direct et on peut
donc supposer imaginer que les amis de
jean marie le pen et les écologistes et
descendent août par la proportionnelle
réaliseront des scores qui peuvent
handicaper les partis traditionnels
s'il est vrai que les socialistes
sortent renforcés des municipales
l'élection européenne ne se traduira pas
obligatoirement par un score excellent
pour le ps soumis à la fois aux
pressions du parti communiste d'un côté
et de l'autre côté par les verts c'est
la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs les
candidats pour mener la liste socialiste
ne sont pas pour l'instant très nombreux
dans l'autre camp incertitude également
les divisions de la droite et la
présence du front national pèseront d'où
les appels répétés à l'union et au
rajeunissement entendu plusieurs fois
hier mais le rendez vous européen sera
bien celui qui fixera plus clairement
les rapports de force politiques où l'on
verra sans doute que le pays change
peut-être un peu plus vite les appareils
politiques et qu'il s'est bien décliner
à sa manière la fameuse ouverture une
histoire de fuseau horaire comme disait
michel noir en tout cas c'est une raison
plus pour écouter attentivement tout à
l'heure pierre méhaignerie le président
du cds sera l'invité de l'heure de
vérité
tout de suite après ce journal passant
au front social est d'abord aux
enseignants lionel jospin a publié cet
après midi ses dernières propositions en
matière de revalorisation un effort pour
tous immédiat et durable à la fois dit
il
les syndicats les étudierons tout au
long de la semaine et n'ont pas
l'habitude de descendre dans la rue v
cinq femmes ont manifesté cet après midi
devant le ministère de la santé pour la
première fois elles feront grève demain
elle reproche à claude evin de ne pas
les avoir consultés à propos de leur
nouveau statut
elle veut aussi améliorer leur salaire
la semaine s'annonce agitée
globalement dans les hôpitaux avec
quelques lits préavis de grève de
syndicats et de coordination
ce réquisitoire est une trahison
c'est ainsi que la des avocats des
parties civiles au procès du commissaire
jobic accueilli ce matin la prestation
du procureur le réquisitoire blanchi en
effet le policier des accusations de
proxénétisme aggravé et de corruption
passive qui lui avait valu de
comparaître devant le tribunal
correctionnel de nanterre amy roche il a
bien dit que le climat des audiences
avaient été détestable et qu'il
déplorait cette ambiance de passion et
de pression il a bien rendu hommage au
juge d'instruction hayat inter et
scrupuleux mais le procureur daniel
renaud s'est surtout attaché à démolir
les accusations portées contre le
commissaire jobic at-il touché de
l'argent en échange de certaines faveurs
rien n'est établi
il convient donc de requérir un non-lieu
concernant les faits de corruption de
fonctionnaires quant à ceux de
proxénétisme
le procureur sans remédier et il a la
sagesse du tribunal après avoir quand
même précisé qu'à son sens les
dépositions des accusatrices du policier
sont discordantes et contradictoires je
crois qu'on a insisté
l'écriture d'une page très triste de
l'histoire du parquet qui me fait un peu
penser à celle qui a été écrite à
l'occasion du procès abdallah où on a vu
procurer un avocat général demande et
supplier une bienveillance d'une cour
d'assises pour un terroriste
j'ai l'impression qu'on est dans la même
situation pour des raisons qui
m'échappent les réquisitions du parquet
sont conformes à ce que dit le dossier
et je crois que c'est bien que le
procureur de la république et demandé au
tribunal de dire le droit et de rendre
justice dernier à parler
les avocats du commissaire jobic
débuteront demain leurs plaidoiries des
jarres assouplissement de la position
des douze européens vis-à-vis de l'iran
et de la fère rushdie ils feront
individuellement renvoyer à téhéran
leurs ambassadeurs mais ils
s'interdisent toujours les visites à
haut niveau
32 morts au moins dont trois
journalistes
c'est dans un climat de peur et de
guerre civile que le salvador a tenté
hier d'élire un nouveau président
l'extrême droite a prononcé sa victoire
martine laroche-joubert arena le parti
d'extrême droite vainqueur
mauvais présage semble-t-il pour un
retour à la démocratie dans un pays
ensanglanté par neuf ans de guerre
civile
pourtant le futur président alfredo
cristiani présente une allure rassurante
quarante deux ans homme d'affaires
formés dans les universités américaines
il se déclare prêt à négocier avec les
guerriers rose du front farabundo martí
discours mesuré à l'opposé du carnage et
de la douleur vont du scrutin d'hier 32
morts trois journalistes tués
semble-t-il par l'armée g
suite à l'appel au boycott lancé par la
guérilla un boycott qui a provoqué des
affrontements violents entre l'armée et
les rebelles
ils ont attaqué des postes militaires et
de fait les routes vers les bureaux de
vote
résultat un paradoxe pour cette élection
40% d'abstentions un succès dont aussi
pour la guérilla victoire des extrêmes
échec pour le successeur de napoléon
duarte candidat de la démocratie
chrétienne
un échec qui dépasse le salvador est
atteint les états unis furent à côté du
futur président se tiennent en effet le
redoute est majeur de lui sont
soupçonnés par les américains d'être le
chef des escadrons de la mort dur quand
on veut faire du salvador un modèle pour
l'amérique centrale au liban l'aviation
israélienne a attaqué des bases
palestiniennes contrôlé par la faction
soupçonné d'être à l'origine de
l'attentât du boeing de la panam inde
consignes et au moins dix morts une
centaine de blessés
le bombardement par l'aviation
israélienne d'un conte palestiniens dans
la vie car zones sous contrôles syrien
le camp appartenaient au fplp
-commandement général de ahmed jibril
une organisation pro syrienne opposé à
yasser arafat
c'est la première fois depuis plus d'un
an collet d'israéliens praxy près de la
frontière syrienne
on recherche toujours un des huit
contenait retombées du cargo le père
entis au cours de son naufrage lundi
dernier dans la manche se contenait
renferme cinq tonnes de lin dan un
insecticide mortels il a coulé au cours
de son remorquage au nord d'origine
selon greenpeace à londres le risque
pour la vie marine ses films ans risque
réduit au contraire selon la préfecture
maritime de cherbourg
puisque le lindane et peu solubles dans
l'eau froide
premier décollage pour l'avion
hélicoptère v 22 osprey de belles boeing
testé ici en position hélicoptère il
peut se transformer en avion grâce à ces
sur hbo propulseur rotatif la position
avion sera testée prochainement les
protos îles de loos précieuses ont
construit et l'appareil devrait équiper
l'armée américaine à partir de 92 on en
plus de hauteur maintenant avec le
programme spatial européen pour étudier
les phénomènes dû à l'absence de
pesanteur
les scientifiques qui travaillent à
l'envoi d'une équipe européenne dans
l'espace n'ont pas hésité aujourd'hui à
mettre à contribution les journalistes
parmi eux patrick esther alors une
petite expérience classique
à terre on peut verser un verre très
facilement maintenant regardez en
apesanteur ce qu'il va se passer on est
d'abord écrasé l'avion s'incline très
fortement bon et je vais essayer la démo
verser un verre tranquille trente
secondes on est aplati littéralement au
sol on ne pèse plus 70 kg mais 140
ensuite lorsque l'on flotte en
apesanteur
on comprend d'un seul coup facilement
pourquoi les cosmonautes boire avec une
paille
alors c'est pas très propre bien sûr
c'est assez difficile voiliers de
s'offrir un verre etc alors pour
rattraper les cochonneries alors là
c'est encore pire
par ailleurs ce vol prouve qu'il n'est
pas obligatoire d'être à bord d'un
vaisseau cosmique pour connaître les
joies de l'impesanteur voilà vous voyez
mais ça n'est pas fait que pour jouer
c'est également fait pour travailler et
c'est l'objet d'un grand nombre
d'expériences qui sont réalisés en vue
dé préparation des vols cosmique mais
aussi de nouveaux types de matériaux
qu'on va développer dans l'industrie
pour réaliser cette trajectoire
parabolique aux effets étonnants la
caravelle du centre d'essais en vol de
brétigny a été adapté par deux
cosmonautes jean pierre haigneré et jean
françois clervoy la france est le
troisième pays au monde à posséder un
avion de ce petit et la société
novespace a maintenant bien l'intention
de le louer à tous ceux qui en feront la
demande
mais on ne sait pas ce qu'il y avait
dans le vert à nous les belles française
je veux parler des voitures et de la
nouvelle gamme de l'usc citroën avant
peu jour dévoile aujourd'hui à l'adouber
ce qui nous la fait découvrir cet x ème
qui remplace la cx avant de nous révéler
aussi les dessins d'une renault est
toujours à l'avant elle a des airs de
ferrari daytona sur le côté elle tient
de la rover
l'arrière est pure tradition site web le
but de ces concepteurs était de réaliser
une grande routière à la fois sport et
confort
l'innovation technique est réelle en
particulier une suspension intelligente
mariage de l'hydraulique et de
l'électronique des performances donc
dans un habitacle équipé de tout ce qui
fait le plaisir de conduire
selon citroën car nous n'avons pas
encore plus essayer cette voiture
autre nouveauté mais cette fois pour
l'année prochaine il est donc un an la
régie renault pour trouver un nom à
cette voiture un nom autre que super
super 5 plus longue de 15 centimètres
plus habitable plus soignée paraît-il
que sa soeur cadette des airs de
japonaise des motorisations nombreuses
selon le journal l'action automobile
elle devrait être lancée au prochain
salon de genève la 105 peugeot nous la
verrons sur les routes au printemps 91
elle sera légèrement plus courte que la
205 mais tout aussi habitable
semble-t-il grâce à une implantation
mécanique très étudiée et ne remplacera
pas la 205
mais viendra plutôt compléter la gamme
peugeot il est timide
il est italien il a arraché des larmes
aux critiques et aux acheteurs qui
suivent ces jours ci les présentations
de prêt à porter à paris par mieux
denrées josé le piqueur qui nous
présente romeo jill la collection la
plus attendue de la semaine c'est celle
de la jeune gloire du prêt-à-porter
italien romeo gigli a délaissé milan
pour présenter sa collection à paris
dans la cour carrée du louvre lainage
rugueux satin velours palette de tons
subtils broderies d'or et d'argent
on
à l'aspiration c'était la latte byzantin
est l'auteur de rats et tous les coloris
dont les mosaïques au tout ça
m
pourquoi venir à paris
guigui n'est pas le premier à franchir
les halles des noms célèbres sont déjà
là le grand couturier valentino a
annoncé qu'il abandonnait rome prestige
prépondérance de paris capitale mondiale
de la mode
pourtant demain promeo djeghri retourne
en italie son équipe ces affaires sont
là bas à paris on montre la mode mais
les financiers du prêt-à-porter de luxe
les industries de fabrication sont en
italie aussi bien pour les créateurs
italiens ou pour les français superbe
dans un instant laurent cabrol va vous
parler du temps demain ensuite l'heure
de vérité et c'est henri sannier tout
jeune et pourtant ancien maire réélu
brillamment au premier tour qui vous
présentera le dernier journal les
dernières informations
vers 23h10 demain vous avez rendez vous
avec toute l'équipe de télématin à
partir de 6h45 et 7h45
gérard morin recevra le secrétaire
général de force ouvrière marc blondel
pour les quatre vérités
voilà très bonne soirée sur un n 2 à
demain 20 heures
m
ap